[Music]
[Applause]
finally another great shooter joining us
on the program dirk nowitzki a member of
the nba 75th anniversary team joining us
on the program when's the last time you
uh went out and shot dirk
hey dan how's it going um it's been a
minute uh you know i've been we've been
staying busy with other things and uh
you know been playing more and more
tennis in my retirement so i haven't
played that much hoops at all
how did you end up at duke for the coach
k
farewell tour
great question i have uh we have a few
friends here that all went to duke and
they're big supporters and they always
said hey you got to go
uh to duke one time you got to go to
cameron indoor and check out the
atmosphere and so it's always kind of
like a bucket list thing for me and and
when they basically invited me for for
this coach k last game i said it's a
no-brainer you know it's a bucket list i
want to go anyways and now to get uh get
to see uh coach k's last game so it was
a no-brainer
and it was an unbelievable atmosphere i
mean
an atmosphere that i usually only see in
europe where guys jumping all game long
and throwing stuff and
um that was amazing but just
you know unc stealing the game at the
end was a little bit of a buzz kill
uh but i still had a i had a great time
did you get scholarship offers in
germany
i had i had a few offers back in the
days i actually visited some colleges i
visited uh kentucky at the time i
visited uh cal and stanford not sure i
would have gotten into stanford with uh
with what i performed in high school i
think they would have gotten in dirk
they somehow kentucky would have got you
and that's for sure uh i would i would
probably think i would have gotten into
kentucky so those those are the three i
looked at and uh i decided then to go
straight in the nba and obviously that
was uh that was the right decision for
me at the time who was the first pro you
ever faced first american pro
um
what did you mean my first nba game or
no when when you came over when like
international games or when you first
got drafted like the first nba player
you you faced was it in your first nba
game
no actually we had uh the nike did a a
promo tour through through germany and
europe back in the days it was called
the hoop heroes and
they had a team that was stacked it was
remember scotty pip and charles barkley
was on it uh jay kidd gary payton
uh vin baker tons tons more and they
played two or three games throughout
europe and so i got to play the against
them at the time i was just in the army
i finished high school then i went to
the army for 10 months so i played uh
played against him twice in berlin and
dortmund i believe and that was really
my first time seeing like the real stars
and it was a fun up and down game and i
had a blast and that's when after the
game famously uh charles
offered me a scholarship to auburn i
said i'm going to get you into auburn
even though albert hadn't recruited me
at the time but he said he could make it
happen so that was that was sweet what
was your role in the army
so i did uh back in the days it was
mandatory uh in germany so i did two
months basic training and then i kind of
got into like a sports company which
then allowed me to stay home and really
start training with hover at the time
really start training professionally uh
started training twice or three times a
day
and uh and so that's uh that was that
was when uh the rest of the eight months
and then basically once i got out of the
army i came uh i came over i was drafted
and i came over to the maps do you ever
wish you had gone to college at least
for one year in the states you know what
uh people have asked me when i was
sitting there and uh soaking up the duke
atmosphere at cameron doors i mean uh
one year i think would have been fun but
as you know my style was a little
different i think
if i would have gotten to college i
think they would have put me in the
weight room first and put me on the
block and i don't you know it's it was
still old school then it was the game
was different i was really skinny
and my worry was that they would change
my game a little bit and put a little
bit more weight on me and put the better
back to the basket and so
uh going to to the nba and going to don
nelson of course who was a mismatch
master at the time and he thought the
game a lot different so
that worked out perfectly for me i gotta
say you know he supported me he let me
shoot threes he let me play my game and
so
uh uh oh dawn a lot if even if i would
have gone to the nba and come to a
different situation things would have
might have changed uh changed my outcome
but you look at this and you did change
the game
you know michael jordan we can say
changed the modern game you could say
that steph curry has changed the game
but for big men to go outside you guys
were always yelled at to go inside get
on the block
seven-footer shooting and shooting as
well as you did
you changed the game did you realize at
the time that you you're changing the
game or the perception of big men
i appreciate that um
you know there was a few big men
obviously they could shoot before me
whether it was shrimp was a german
legend or whether it was ku koch and
some guys that spread the floor
i think i came in at a time when when
the when the league was changing you
know with the league was putting in the
zone defense uh it was getting rid of
some of the hand checking from the 90s
so
uh
so i think that the game was changing in
more of a free free-flowing passing game
a pick-and-roll game away from you know
somebody dribbling 10 seconds on the iso
on the wings i think the game changed
and i was
i was fortunate that i was i was there
at the time when the game was changing
and i was uh you know now it's it's fun
to watch these big guys come in all
skilled all can bring up the ball can
initiate the offense could shoot
composed and
i mean the versatility from the bigs
these days it's just fun to watch well i
wonder the impact that maybe larry bird
had on you here's a six nine guy who was
a great shooter winning the three-point
shooting contest i don't know who
impacted you growing up where
you thought hey i it's okay for me to go
outside or i can perfect this
so i'm i was a huge nba fan starting in
the 90s i just missed larry um so i was
more of a chicago bulls fan in the 90s
there of course then i got to know larry
and did research on the league and so
obviously he's one of the best ever
but in the 90s there when when i grew up
um there was there was just just before
my time so i was a big bulls fan you
know back in the day in germany they
only would show one or two games a week
and it was all always usually the best
team so i was a die-hard bulls fan
you know with with ku coach and uh and
later on and so yeah i saw my game more
like that more facing the basket i
didn't have a big frame i was super
skinny i weighed maybe 220 pounds max
and
um so i was uh yeah it was it was easier
for me to to move
and face the basket always than than
with the back to the basket what was it
like the first time you met michael
jordan
so you know mj retired with the shot
game six in utah i was drafted that
summer then we had the lockout and i'm
thinking i'm about to play against my
hero against my uh
idol and then he retired and i'm like oh
no i've just missed my hero by a few
months
so he didn't come back for the lockout
year in 99 and 1999 so i didn't get a
chance to play against them and then
he came back with the wizards a few
years later and of course he was he was
a little up there in age but it was
still amazing i mean i was in awe he
guarded me a couple possessions on the
post and i tried to post them up and i
was so excited i remember just shooting
a brutal fade away i don't think i even
made it but i was just so so hyped to
play against mj and be on the same court
as
my idol but
you know the first my first you really
arrived in the nba moment was i think my
third or fourth nba game in the lockout
year was against houston
the rockets and at the time in 98 99
they had pippin who i loved from the
balls they had charles barkley who i
loved
and they had hakeem olajuwon who i
watched in the 90s winning back-to-back
championship so i'm like i'm running
around on this court thinking what is
happening here this is super surreal so
that was that was my definitely i have
arrived in the nba moment did you ever
ask for a jersey from these guys
i did not i didn't want to be that guy
you know i was first of all i was way
too shy
i wouldn't have even known how to
address them or talk to them so i kind
of like did my thing and then i went in
the locker room i didn't didn't really
have the cuts to do it
how much trash did they talk to you
i mean not not not that trio but there
was obviously when i first got the
league of skinny i was from europe i was
shooting jumpers so you know everybody
was kind of like hey he's soft let's see
what he's made of and i remember i was i
was guarding somebody
right in front of the opposing bench and
all i can hear from the bench go at him
he is soft
like flow by him and so so i mean i
heard all these things of course i hear
all these things and yeah i thought it
motivated me to to push through and get
a little stronger and and work on my
game and uh you know how did kevin
garnett treat you
uh he tried to be
pretty intimidating uh always
especially at the beginning of my career
when we were getting better with dallas
um
we were we were pushing into the
playoffs there my first two years we
missed the players my third year we
finally met playoffs and then
you know he tried to intimidate me and
you know sometimes there'll be a timeout
i'd walk out of the timeout he had
already left his time out early to stand
there
and
walk with me
nose to nose almost
and and uh that was kg i love this his
passion is intensity and he was a little
crazy so we have two great battles over
the year obviously
you know
the the the pierce's competitor also
bring out the best in you and you try to
you know hold your own and so we've had
some great battles over our careers
you know kobe closes out his career with
60.
like that doesn't happen dirk like how
do you explain that night that kobe just
goes for 60 and says see you
ah unbelievable i mean to me
you know i played against you know shaq
and timmy d and and all the the great
players to meet kobe was was the
greatest in his prime that uh that i
faced and i and i always always tell the
story when
when we played in la i think it was all
six or seven he
he scored 63 to three quarters and we as
a team scored 62 and he outscored us by
himself
and i mean there was nothing we could do
that night he shot floaters he he was on
the break one on four he was laying us
he was fade away there was one time we
got stuck in the corner and uh
and the the shot clock was going down so
he just turned over and shot a three out
of the corner with the left
bottoms and like
there was nothing that night because he
his his his killer mentality his
athleticism and his skill level was just
elite everything the whole package was
elite so
there was just nothing we could do with
him so
to come back to his final game it didn't
surprise me i've i've watched this man
more than probably anybody else
uh while i was in my in the nba i always
try to catch his fourth quarter
somewhere in la you know before i go to
bed i'm like oh kobe's playing the home
game in in stables i gotta i gotta tune
in something is about to happen so i
never made it a big secret i was i was a
big admirer and a big fan from afar and
uh had a huge amount of respect so that
to score 16
in this final game i don't think anybody
was surprised and then he scores 81. i
is somebody going to score 100 in a game
i mean it's it's going to be tough i
mean if if somebody's going to do it
it's going to be in the nowadays game
you know not in
in the 90s it was pretty much impossible
with with the physical style but
now the scoring is up uh and the court
is way more open and so i mean if
somebody can do it it'll be now but i
mean it's i don't see it but you know
you never say never you know the records
are always there to to be broken but uh
we'll see what happens but it's actually
funny when kobe had 63 on us
he didn't play the whole fourth quarter
because they were up 20-25
then a couple weeks later against
toronto he had to play the whole game
and he got 81. uh i for sure think if he
would have played on us the whole game
he would easily scored 80-85 i mean
that's how he was he was going nuts and
so that's that's the type of role he was
on in that in that couple weeks stretch
and it was it was unbelievable but can
you
you're born obviously with certain
traits characteristics
certain players have michael jordan had
that i'm going to kill you kobe had that
i'm going to kill you
can can you acquire that like if you
look at that and go
i need to have more of that in my game
can can you put killer instinct assassin
into your game
ah that is that is a tough question i
think you can work on certain stuff
you can work on for sure the mental
aspect of the game i'm not sure all of a
sudden you can turn in the mj or kobe
but i do think the the mental part is
huge it's huge now i think
uh we learned so much about um
about your mental um approach to the
game the last 20 30 years you know we we
didn't know much back in the days we
didn't know much about nutrition when i
first got in the 90s we were eating
burgers pregame we were you know we were
doing all sorts of stuff and nobody
really trained their mind and their
brain and now now the last 20 years i
think we know so much more
and all these athletes now are like
vegan and have mental trainers and
coaches and so
i think that's that's definitely an era
an area where where you can work on and
improve but i'm not sure you can turn
into into michael jordan i think that's
that's something he was just born with
but i don't know if you know when the
miami heat and wade and lebron sort of
mocked you for coughing if you and your
mind
like do you turn something on and use
that against them in the nba finals
uh not really you know at the time when
i saw the video we were up 3-2 and we're
going to miami and so we're we're
literally one game away from my dream
that i've been chasing for i was in
league i think 11 years already
and i always felt short so
um you know if anything i i told the
team i said let's stick together and
let's uh let's let's close this out and
then
the funny thing in game six then maybe i
was pressing even too hard i think i
don't know if you remember but at half
time of game six i was one for 12. uh
probably one of the worst uh
performances of anybody and a half in a
finals game
and it took me a little bit i don't know
if i was too hyped i wanted to force
things
uh maybe the whole mocking thing you
know i tried to force it even more and
things were just not happening but
second half i was i was able to slow
down a little bit and let the game come
to me a little more and we ended up
winning in game six
so
that was uh that was probably one of the
worst halves ever played by somebody in
the finals do you hold any grudges
with anybody
no not at all i think you know i think
it's normal when you're in the league
and you're competing at the highest
level every night to not be friendly
with everybody you know i think there
were some guys that got along a little
better there's some guys that we didn't
really talk much
uh but i think that's part of being a
competitor but also you know once my
career is over now you know
made peace with everybody and i don't
have any hard feelings i i doubt there's
a lot of guys that have heart feelings
towards me
uh so it's just i try to compete i try
to win and then you know you know now
it's over it's we all had a good time
do you want to coach
be a gm
you know i'm not really sure what the
future brings honestly i've been
enjoying uh traveling my children have
three young kids and i'm enjoying being
home and traveling with them a lot and
i do some advising for the math at the
moment
to do other things uh learn about
business side and
uh you know we still have i have two
foundations one in germany one here in
the us so i stay busy
but you know we'll see what the future
brings i'm not a coach i would say
that's uh that's not my mentality to
stand there and motivate guys and hold
big speeches that was never my thing
even while i played
i was more the guy that led by example i
never wanted to stand in front of the
team and talk so i don't think that's in
my my dna but you know maybe some front
office stuff in in the future but well
we'll see what happens i think it's it's
a little too early for me i'm enjoying
my time with the family for now if i
said describe luka doncic to people
who've never seen him play
how would you describe it
i mean honestly he's
a complete package he's a big guard uh
he's
he's got everything in his game and
offensively that you would hope for i
mean he's he can break you down off the
dribble he's not the fastest guy he's a
big guy six nine big guy but uh you know
can can has has the skills as the the
strength
uh can go by anybody once he has you on
his butt on his shoulder he's so strong
he just can move anybody
and he's got the uh the big shot
mentality he's got the confidence to
take over in big moments so
he can post he worked on his floater
last couple years so now he's got the
in-between game
i mean honestly uh he is
as full of a package as a 23 year old as
i've seen because uh usually you know
how he reads the game how you reach the
pick-and-roll situation how he passed
the ball usually i think you develop
that more as you get more experience
this kid came in at 20 19 20 years old
and the way he saw the game was uh was
was something i've never seen in my
career so
we're we're so happy he's uh he's
playing for the mouse of course were you
ever called for an offensive foul when
you would do your little step back and
put your knee into somebody's groin
yeah not not not when i shot it but
sometimes i got it when i try to create
space and somebody was really on me and
i'd really try to put my shoulder down
and create
that little bit of you know separation
that i needed i think
especially later in my career when guys
knew that i was coming i didn't really i
couldn't really drive uh and i did so
they were really up on my shoulder and
then when i did try to lower it a little
bit i think that's when i got some
offense foul but once i got the little
separation and i was leaning back
i don't think i ever got uh got that
call as much test fell yeah but you were
you were using your leg as a weapon dirk
i mean a little bit but like i said that
you first you first create the
separation with backing somebody down
and then once you take a step back you
know it's not like i
i bumped and then immediately shot i did
step back from from a little from one
felt to the other from the right leg to
the left and that is already creating
enough separation
to raise the the knee up so i never
really need anybody uh in the groin or
in other areas during that shot that
never really happened has mark cuban
ever been the best shooter on the team
uh never uh he i think in his his his
mind he believes he was uh but
honestly he's uh he played a little bit
obviously uh as a hobby and he's got a
little stroke but it's it's a super
super slow slow release
uh
but uh you know he was just a super fan
when we first when he bought the team we
used to play one-on-one in shooting
games after practice all the time and
that's the kind of relationship we had
and so he's he's been sort of a mentor
and
uh and obviously a good friend of mine
for for a long long time so i do i do
owe him a lot uh thanks for opening up
the scrapbook we appreciate you uh
telling stories there dirk thank you
very much yeah no thank you guys for
having me take care that's dirk nowitzki